making thousands nearly everyday from my
phone and my laptop millionaire coaches
always intrigued us but like many we're
skeptical of them too especially the
ones who guarantee that they can help us
turn a few hundred dollars into Millions
so when Steven ducks an online
millionaire coach inquired if he could
be a sponsor in order to share his story
and his method we had our reservations
but then we realized it would be a great
opportunity to explore this phenomenon
of millionaire coaches and agreed to
have Steven on the show only under the
conditions that he would be honest about
his life his work and of course allow
our audience to ask him anything hi my
name is Steven Dux I'm a millionaire
I've turned twenty seven thousand into
five million dollars within four years
by trading stocks have come here to
answering any questions
[Music]
maybe you're the first millionaire I've
ever had a chance to have an actual
conversation with I guess this was gonna
be my first question but how old are you
I'm 25 years old now that are frying you
oh I have grandchildren probably as old
as you are has anybody ever thought you
were lying like when you mentioned it to
them well my neighbor and I think I'm my
drug dealer
do you think it's epical to accumulate
so much wealth and not give back to
society
what depends on how they accumulate
their wealth and if they're helping
people while community wealth
I think it's ethical this is an
oversimplification but if you made two
million dollars it might be fair to say
that 20 people lost $100,000 are you
okay with that yeah very interesting
question it's a very competitive society
so you have to be responsible to your
for your own mistakes
not bring others are you a math whiz
sort of what's 88 times 75 I don't know
what does the day look like in your life
it would help a Nyame around 8 and 9 and
look at the general market and make a
decision should I check today or not if
I trade that will stay about extra two
hours it's like your first thing you do
yes first of all okay no it's after that
we just go to lunch that's what you eat
for lunch what any for not usually
Chipotle nice what's the craziest thing
you've spent a large amount of money on
okay so I'm a huge car fan I had a
Ferrari 488 spider that cost about
around 500k did you like grow up like
being financially stable or so I was
exchange student from from China I came
here when I was 16 backing obviously the
70s my mom was already a millionaire and
my dad was a soldier which is considered
to be poor in that stay so my mom had my
brother and we have to move to a
different city my mom sold all their
business to my dad and my dad become
multi-millionaire a lot of meetings
he basically changed into an entire
different person there's more family
violence there's more
you know cursing and the families and my
mom was basically in suffering and he
wasn't appreciate at all from my mom
basically give all he's her moaning to
him just start as no as a investment the
beginning I'm not comfortable seeing
that type of people and even though my
dad has a medians I'm not looking up to
him so my mom always taught me that yeah
it doesn't really matter you have money
or not you has to you have to respect
people it has to respect people that who
helped you at the beginning I want to
you know become the opposite of my dad
even though I went from the bottom to
the top I was still won't become the
person that that kid did do you ever
think of the fact that people like
Warren Buffett or Ray Dalio
come out really strongly against day
trading how so many financial experts
would say that day trading is akin to
gambling how many professional football
players can make over two million
dollars a year not that many and how
many people try to play professional
football a lot and the only successful
people can be about weighting 10% same
thing with date ratings and you forego
into this industry if you're not
prepared to be the top percent and you
just want to get in there and make quick
money and then you're gonna be another
90% people going to lose money do you
believe that anyone can become a
millionaire I don't believe anyone can
become a millionaire because a lot of
people don't really have the motivations
to do it second they don't really want
to step out their comfort zones do you
ever feel anxious and how you might calm
your own anxiety I do get a lot of you
know anxious at the beginning as well
the first major mistakes we make the
second thought is I want to make that
money back now as soon as you have that
second thought you make the second
mistake there is a chain reaction you
keep making mistakes until you blow up
your account the way to deal with I just
show them comparing to come back fresh
in the next day and not people can't do
that it's very difficult to control your
emotions especially you're playing with
real money but it just takes practices
it seems as though when you describe
your methods you can make money at will
if that's the case then why sell classes
and if you searched about day trading
there is a lot of skins I'm the victim
of that type of courses so I generally
that one course it's full with content
no [ __ ]
and just go straight to the point I want
to become the opposite of how there are
certain courses but if it was really
about helping people and you're like
financially set you've got millions of
dollars then wouldn't you just want to
like give away this information or
charge considerably less when I study
that I spend ten hours a day 365 days
with no break that's for the first year
and I can't just give stuff out there
for free has your millions brought you a
lot of happiness the more money you can
you know young age the less friend do
you have you have it's because you don't
really have a similar topic and once you
spend majority time you know diving into
the market and a lot of people in
college that are spending their time
partying and building their
relationships and you guys don't really
have a similar topic as being a
millionaire impacted your relationships
well you can't kind of tell people are
coming for you as a person or for your
money and being a millionaire you get a
lot of and straightforward gold diggers
yeah where do you usually meet people
probably work space I work a lot I don't
really go out that much do you have a
girlfriend
nope no yeah no do you think you need to
when you date somebody you need to find
somebody else who shares that interest
with you yes and that's the reason why
it's so hard to find a girlfriend when I
meet people I was a little bit shy and
don't really know how to talk to people
and when I talk to girls and I know
pretty much 50% of the info in my head
are about you know generating data's and
engineering xand numbers don't really
share in the same interest it's hard to
get along have you had like a successful
long-term relationship where you felt
like someone was interested in who you
are as a person and not your money yes I
had one but it was a heartbreaking one
that's where I started trading and
trying to be better off my
so that heartbreak inspired you to start
trading yes Wow
so you were not a millionaire during
this relationship no I was not no have
you had contact with this person does
she now see like man I missed out I
don't think she cares yeah that's the
problem so I so I started dating this
girl when I was 19 and at that time I
wasn't trading I wasn't having any type
of money at all I was an engineering
student I was so dedicating to this
relationship
and I spent pretty much all my money to
follow ring and once I bought a ring
about to propose and she turned around
and said she was with a third man and
that's yeah that's where just I turn
into a completely different person once
you go through a breakup and first thing
you want to do is you want to know you
think yourself are not good and you want
to get better and I started to you know
start investing and save my money and go
to the gym and become better myself and
being going good since there well I feel
like that emotional driving force was
something that kind of lady to kind of
take away the negativity and it's really
tough to go through as you know 20 year
old gay that is yeah that's so true well
thank you so much for sharing that was
really cool to be able to hear your
story and I appreciate that thank you
for watching the video
Stephen would you like to mention where
they can find information on your
products so you can find my courses as
Stephen Docs account and currently we
are building this AI system and konima
strategies of the scanners currently
still in beta test versions so we're
likely to release during the sprint
and we're also accepting the amount of
spots so you don't get your emails down
linking descriptions I'll have to accept
that please like and subscribe if you
enjoyed the video bye
you
[Music]